hello friends I'm finally back in the UK
and you will be delighted to hear that
that means a return to the twice a week
podcast publishing schedule so let's get
into it this week I'm sitting down with
Christy Ashwin Dhin who is the author of
good to go what the athlete in all of us
can learn from the strange science of
recovery that one of my favorite
episodes so far was with Alex Hutchinson
on the limits of human performance as he
explained what he discovered during
research for his book endure and today
we're going to look at everything on the
opposite end of that spectrum so from
fancy foam rollers to cryogenic therapy
saunas sleep optimization those
compression pant things those weed
compression pump things and every other
form of recovery that you can think of
and you've seen athletes using on
Instagram we're going to go through them
today Christie has done a fantastic
analysis of all of the different ways
that people are trying to recover and
assess just what sort of impact they're
having so if you are an athlete or you
know one who is looking to improve their
recovery then today is absolutely for
you
please welcome Christy Ashwin
[Music]
Christie Ashwin Dhin how are you today
I'm great thanks for having me thank you
for coming on so what are we going to
learn about today exercise recovery all
things that have to do with exercise
recovery okay
recently some of the guests will know
the spot on the back of your book that
mr. Alex Hutchinson the the man behind
injure is a big proponent a big big
supporter of your book and obviously
what he was talking about was a lot of
the things to do within training what's
happening while you train and the
experiences that you go through during a
session and you're now talking about
everything else I guess yeah that's
right and I think that the to really
make nice companion books his book is
all about training itself whereas mine
is about the recovery process and all of
these adaptations and things that happen
in between workouts fantastic so why
does the book begin it actually begins
at a place called Denver Sports recovery
which is one of many I like to think of
them as recovery spas that have popped
up all around the US I'm not sure
actually is a thing in the UK as well
I'm gonna guess is it one of those
places where there's a cryo chamber and
you can get an IV drip of nutrients and
stuff like that yes right exactly no
unfortunately in the in the UK that's
that's reserved for kind of elite level
athletes it's not the sort of thing you
can go up with spar and have a massage
in and go in a hot tub but there's
that's probably about the top end I
think of what you can get in the UK
unfortunately yeah that's interesting I
know that there are a few in Australia
as well but it's definitely become a
thing here in the US these places you
can go in and for a fee there are all
sorts of things so it's not just massage
and cryotherapy you mentioned IVs which
is another another common thing but
there are also all kinds of rollers
there are those I call them squeezy
pants but they have their pneumatic
compression sleeves that you they're
sort of like sleeping bags for your legs
you put them on and then they they blow
up with air and compress your muscles
and
it frankly feels really nice that's
another popular one they'll have ice
baths saunas pretty much everything that
you can purchase that would be used for
recovery can be found at these places at
these recovery spas Wow okay so you're
at this far and what's the what's the
story from that yeah so that was kind of
an introduction for me I'm looking at
okay when I was a leat at leat so I'll
just step back for a second I used to be
a runner then I became a cross-country
skier and cyclist and when I was doing
these these things that sort of an elite
level in the early 2000s and late 90s
recovery was really something that we
weren't doing it was something and what
I mean by that is it was all these
things that we weren't doing you weren't
standing up you weren't staying out late
at night you weren't running around
doing other stressful things so recovery
was really about you know lying on the
couch maybe putting your nose in a book
but putting your feet up and resting
maybe you took a nap or something but
now sort of in the interim recovery has
become its own thing and almost an
extension of training where people are
doing all of these things they're
putting on these squeezy pants they're
massaging all of their muscles with a
foam roller they're getting massage and
massage is something that is that is
very old and was done in my time as well
but it's become something where there's
a sense that you need to do all these
things that it's not enough to just lie
back and wait for recovery to happen but
you need to do things to facilitate it
it's a train hard recover hard right
exactly exactly if you're not recovering
hard then you know you're not doing
enough oh I totally get it
so what during the course of writing
this book where was your mindset before
you began because you know for me
personally I do see a lot of you know
foam rollers that vibrate and there's
one that you know this wouldn't have a
Wi-Fi connection and this one plays your
Bluetooth music and you know and you
think that okay so how far do I need to
go with these marginal games before it
becomes sweating the small stuff
so we're when our minds
why was your mindset before all of this
we use skeptical of recovery or yeah
that's a great question so I really
tried to go into it with an open mind so
I am a science writer by training and by
vocation and I think it's really
important if you are having a scientific
mindset that means always being open to
new evidence to sort of keeping an open
mind and making sure that you're truly
looking at the evidence before you
without too much bias and all of that so
I went into it thinking you know wow
things have really changed since since
you know I was a serious athlete and
maybe this is something really important
that I need to know about but I also had
a level of skepticism because I thought
you know this didn't always square with
the things that I had experienced as an
athlete and some of the things that I
knew so I guess I would say I went in
with an open but skeptical mind so it
was sort of like trust but verify I
think is a really good mantra and an
explanation of how how I went into this
so I was definitely open to the idea
that some of this stuff this newfangled
stuff was really important and in fact I
did find things that were good and that
yeah there are some new things that I
have adopted for myself after
researching this book but it also turned
out that a lot of the things you know
really weren't all that they were made
out to be I think that's right
unfortunately it's an area where
especially when we're talking about
marginal gains here it's so easy for a
product to hide behind the fact that it
doesn't work with a clever marketing
campaign the direction of causality is
is super like who knows that some days I
wake up and I feel fantastic and I've
only had six hours sleep you know was it
because of the very particular bath
salts that I had that I thought you know
I liked was it the incense that was
burning in the corn or you know is it
just a quirk of the fact that you're a
dynamic system right right I think
that's a good point we are dynamic
systems our bodies are very adaptable
too and that's the other thing we've
sort of been taught or sold may be this
idea that you know everything has to be
optimal and then it's possible to
optimize your body and if you can just
optimize if there's this magical
thing that will happen and that yeah you
may be performing well now but but if
you can get just all systems to this you
know mythical optimal state that
everything will be perfect
and it turns out that although look I
think that there is some truth to that
it's also true that our bodies are
really really good at adapting to
different environmental conditions I
mean we evolved to you'll be able to
handle heat and cold and all of these
things that we might throw at it and so
you know we're pretty good at performing
under different conditions and so
although there may be things that you
can do that will help a little bit I
think that the expectations that we have
here are oversized yeah so I mean so you
talked about marginal gains and I think
that that's an interesting way of
putting it and this is sort of one idea
that's out there that like well you can
do these things that on their own are
really small but if you put them
together then you know so if you have a
bunch of things that only make a one or
two percent difference that may not seem
like a lot but if you do five or six of
them then all of a sudden you know you
may be getting to six or seven or eight
percent difference and that's really
huge and again in sport even those small
percent differences can be very
meaningful I mean in a race a 1%
difference could be the difference
between the winner and someone who's an
also-ran
so that's one idea that's really been
put out there now there's a lot of talk
sometimes people who talk about marginal
gains have been accused of you know
using that as a way of explaining gains
that might have been made by more
illicit means and that's a whole debate
that I don't want to get into you but I
assume that you're familiar with some of
that conversation yeah I'm sure that
everyone who's listening will be so
before we before we get into the meat of
the individual elements did you come up
with the definition or did you find an
appropriate definition for exercise
recovery yeah that's a great question
and that's kind of where I started and I
thought okay the first thing I need to
do is define this and it was like oh
crap like this is actually a lot harder
than I thought and everyone I talked to
you would have a different definition I
mean in terms of looking at it
scientifically like what are the factors
that will show that you're recovered and
what do we really mean by this
and so I guess I would just say that on
its most basic level I think recovery is
really about a return to readiness so
you've done a heart bout of exercise and
recovery is basically that just means
that your your body is recuperated it's
rusted it's ready to go hard again so
whatever processes need to go on and
between those bouts have happened and
it's it's this return to readiness that
really underlies it across the entire
system right right okay so you found
your definition when did you where did
you move from that what were the first
things that you looked into so I started
looking at okay what's really happening
in the body when we're recovering and
you know what I found and this this had
squared with sort of what I had learned
back in college and also my experience
as an athlete is that basically a DAP
tations that we make in response to
exercise or things that happen not
during the the training itself but in
the interim so you don't get stronger
you know while you are lifting the
weights you get stronger because your
body you know responds to that
weightlifting that you did and makes
changes and so you're creating like
microscopic damage and the muscles and
the muscle is rebuilding itself and sort
of bolstering itself to become stronger
for the next time and so that's a really
important sort of fundamental concept is
that recovery really is when these
adaptations take place that's something
that I've heard from you know even when
you're a gym bro I need 18 years old and
you start doing your first come first
coach a gym you hear all about the the
fact that you don't grow in the gym you
grow when you sleep and I think even
then I had a massive amount of
skepticism I'm like oh yeah whatever
mate like you know I just need to I just
need to lift more weight but your
suggestion is that that's that's correct
it is and I'll also just say it's
interesting that you bring up you know
your younger self because almost
universally as I was speaking to
athletes about recovery and particularly
very accomplished and and athletes who
had been in the game for a long time
they almost universally told me that
yeah when I was younger when I was first
starting out I really didn't give
recovery the attention it deserved
and I thought it wasn't a big deal and I
never really focused on it or gave it
much of a thought and as athletes age
and as they get more experienced they
realize oh wow this really is you know a
lot of the magic here and one of the
things that I really need to pay
attention to and it's also true that as
you get older your recovery needs
increase so that's another reason that
older athletes sort of have a better
appreciation for recovery than younger
ones I mean when you're when you're
young when you're a teenager athlete you
just made of rubber and fairy dust on
you and you capable of bouncing back
from anything and injuries just you grow
a new arm and you yeah like you lose an
eye you another one comes back like it's
that kind of does feel a bit like that
but yes as you mature through your
athletic career you become chronically
aware of your own mortality yeah totally
so you've defined what exercise recovery
is did you create any broad categories
of what contributes to that yeah so
there are a couple of things and I think
one really important concept that came
to me and I think is sort of
unappreciated or underappreciated by a
lot of athletes is that your body
responds to stress the same whether it
is physical stress or emotional stress
so in other words we often when we're
thinking about recovery think of it in
terms of okay I did a hard workout today
or I didn't or today was a rest day in
terms of what my training was but at the
same time don't give attention to you
okay what kind of stress is going on in
my life what's happening in my personal
life am i stressed at work or if you're
a student-athlete at school and these
other stresses can be just as as well
stressful to your body as the physical
stress and so to really recover well you
need to address the other stresses you
know the psychological and emotional
stresses in your life and this is
something that pretty much every good
coach that I talked to has also sort of
learned and tells their athletes that
you know if on your rest day you're
dealing with stress at work or
difficulties at home you're not really
resting and
you need to find ways to address the
stress in your life did you manage to
quantify the relative contribution to or
degrading of recovery based on those
factors versus that I guess the more
physical ones yeah I mean that's a good
question but I don't think that it has a
hard and fast answer I mean a lot of
this stuff is just extremely hard to
quantify and I have a whole chapter in
the book called I believe the magic
metric and that is all about sort of
attempts to use data to quantify
recovery and find ways to measure it and
it's really interesting I'll just this
is kind of a spoiler but they've been so
many different studies and looking at so
many different physiological factors but
it turns out that in the end nothing
really Trump's just this qualitative
measure of how are you feeling and
things like mood actually are much
better predictor of overtraining than
something like you know something you
could measure in a blood test or on a
heartrate monitor what's very
interesting about that and I'm sure that
some of the listeners will be agreeing
with me is that in injure by Alex
Hutchinson what he talks about is RPE or
as I've kind of readapted it the rate of
perceived discomfort the RPD all right
he uses that and he says you know you
can look yeah yeah you can look at the
lactate threshold and the vo2 max I need
blah blah blah but the best determinant
of someone's capacity to injure is how
they feel under X degree of stress and
you're saying that this I guess what
would we call it our rate of perceived
recovery the RP ha perhaps or the weight
you know that would be that would be the
the best overall aggregate global figure
that you could give yourself yeah that's
right and the book I talked about some
different attempts so there are some
measures that are like little tests or
things that people can keep track of
various factors and again it doesn't go
down to one single thing but looking at
things like mood or paying attention to
just sort of patterns in your life that
people have been working on
there are actually a couple of
interesting apps and sort of
computer-based or diary baits things
that people can use there's a really
good one of the best measures and sort
of trackers for looking at overtraining
and that athletes can use to prevent
themselves from going over the edge
actually looks at mood states and sort
of not just how you're feeling like are
you feeling tired or not but are you
feeling Moody are you feeling depressed
do you feel like trading so it was
really interesting for me to learn that
like I had them someone who during my
athletic career had some bouts of
overtraining and basically when this
happens you just you get in this hole
and you can't get out of it and no
matter what you do you're just tired
your your muscles are blown and you you
just can't you know it you're not coming
back and it turns out and you know when
I was in periods of overtraining I
almost always felt like I didn't feel
like training and I didn't want to Train
and I was in a bad mood and what I
learned while researching this book is
that those feelings and those moods were
not you know at the time I thought well
I'm really terrible here what kind of
athlete am i they don't feel like
training but like that's my body's sake
take a rest you know lay off for a while
and and I think that this is really
common though and in fact I have some
stories in my book about other athletes
of all sorts of different ability levels
and sort of types of athletes who have
gone through this and it's almost
universal I think that if you are an
athlete who's training hard you're just
really inherently driven and so there's
this idea that you know your body may be
telling you I'm tired and you think I
just got to push through this and if I
just go harder or do more the rewards
will be there but it turns out that
that's not how it works so it's so
difficult it's a very nuanced
appreciation to know am i giving up
because I am stopping myself before my
my work is done or am i giving up
because I've pushed myself too hard and
this came up again with Alex or I'm like
where do you draw the line between being
a bit of a [ __ ] with your training and
with your recovery and how do you know
that you're still pushing yourself hard
enough and I suppose suppose the Devils
in the details there so if you were to
take the the foundations the
in terms of the basics of good recovery
would you be able to would you be able
to take us through those who kind of
what what are the building blocks upon
upon which recovery should be started
yeah so the most fundamental and
important building block is sleep I mean
it's really like if you were to ask me
like tell me the one thing that works
its sleep and yeah I would say that the
top 10 or top twins at work for recovery
our sleep sleep sleep sleep sleep like
it's really that important it's sort of
like sleep is the cake and everything
else is just icing it really if you're
not sleeping well and you're not getting
enough sleep you're just everything else
does matter and so sleep is a really
important thing and also just resting
and in the sense of relaxation I guess I
would say so that sort of and by
relaxation I mean this sort of overall
holistic thing where you're not just
sitting still and not exercising but
you're also reducing the stress in your
life and you're feeling relaxed like
that that sort of rejuvenation and
relaxation is really essential to sort
of letting your body do the work that it
needs you're giving it all those
resources to make those repairs and to
make those adaptations that you're
looking for was that a Goldilocks zone
that you found for athletes who are
training let's say the typical athletes
training you know between an hour to two
hours a day five days a week
was there a appropriate amount of sleep
what is it's very massively
person-to-person so sleep is individual
but it doesn't there's a lot of but
let's say oh I sleep six hours and I
feel great and it turns out so there is
a genetic condition that is extremely
rare though I will say like chances are
if you think you're one of these people
you probably are there's a genetic
condition though where some people
really truly only need something like
four or five hours of sleep but this is
something that runs in families it's
it's a very distinct it's not just like
you think you feel okay if you get less
sleep it's something where people just
fundamentally can't sleep longer but
most people who say that they get by
fine and feel great on say six hours of
sleep are actually
fooling themselves and what is true is
that they're just extraordinarily well
adapted to sort of coping with the
impairments that they have on that much
sleep so they're actually fooling
themselves and there's some interesting
studies which I talked about in the book
where they look at people you know who
are sleep sleep impaired and what
happens is the first night after you
don't get enough sleep you feel tired
and you sort of know that you're
impaired and you feel awful but if this
continues what happens is you sort of
stop noticing it and that kind of
cognitive impairment and physical
impairment just becomes the new normal
to you and so while you think that
you're coping well you're not and you
know probably if you asked you know your
your co-workers or friends or whatever
they they might be able to set you
straight as well yeah okay so it's sleep
is important we've said that is there a
is there a minimum amount that you would
recommend for most athletes I mean I
think seven is kind of the minimum and
again this is something individual the
very best way to figure out how much you
need is to have an one night isn't
enough if you're if you're chronically
sleep-deprived it's gonna take you a
while to kind of get caught up to where
you're some sort of baseline but you
have a few nights where you are not
setting alarm don't have any reason to
get up where you can just truly sleep as
long as you as you want to and see how
much how much sleep your body wants but
I would say less than seven you're
you're really playing with fire and a
lot of athletes and having talked to a
lot of athletes while writing this book
it seems as though many many athletes
prefer to get a minimum of eight yeah I
think so for me the the listeners to the
show will know that we are massive
Matthew Walker evangelists on the show
and we've there was a podcast if you
haven't checked it out it's in the 20s I
think maybe number 29 with dr. Greg
Potter from the University of Leeds as
we talk about the definitive guide to
sleep and in that we can talk about
sleep hygiene and the room needs to be a
little bit cooler and a hot shower go to
bed and you know the darkness and do it
in line with the circadian rhythm
sunlight exposure during the day and
dark exposure at night etc it's all the
sleep hygiene stuff and you know the the
specifics of it aside I think the bottom
line is kinda the same as time and
attention right it's like you
you can try and fine-tune your
environment as much as you
but it's the equivalent of buying a
really nice pair of running shoes and
never going out for a run that look like
just just go to sleep and get some sleep
for a bit right absolutely and so much
of it like you like you say is really
about building good habits it shouldn't
be a special you're trying to get more
sleep before a competition or after a
hard workout but that it really becomes
like the way that you live an important
part of your life and really I think
that it's important to note here that
one of the ways that one or one of the
things that needs to happen for this to
you know for you to get good sleep is to
prioritize it you know we're just in an
era where we have things constantly at
us and vying for our attention and it's
really easy to get caught up in screens
and different things and you just have
to say look sleep is a priority for me
and it's something that I'm going to
prioritize over you know there may be
other things that you have to give up or
that you have to give lesser attention
to in order to get that sleep but until
you prioritize it it's just it's not
going to happen for you yeah I get that
so sleep is important how how about
recovering through our diet yes good
question so food is really important for
recovery you're obviously a hard workout
you're burning through carbs protein all
kinds of things you're using energy that
you need to replenish you need to our
muscles are fueled on glycogen so if
these click into the stores and so after
particularly an endurance workout these
can be depleted and so you want to
replenish those stores that what I found
out while research is the book was kind
of interesting and that is yes nutrition
is absolutely important of course it is
but we've kind of made it out to be
something more precise than it is so
it's important to get carbs it's
important to get protein and as you get
older protein becomes a little bit more
important too this is a little bit
preliminary but it seems as though as
you get older your body's ability to
sort of take up protein becomes a little
bit impaired and so you really need to
be sure not to skimp on protein as you
get older and obviously if you're doing
strength training or things that are
really taxing your muscles where there's
going to be a lot of repair going on in
the muscles and the
protein is important but this idea that
there's this magic window recovery
window under which you have to get these
nutrients ends to optimize your recovery
it turns out that that's that's
something that is really overstated
I had one researcher tell me you know
it's not a recovery window it's more
like a recovery barn door but as long as
you're not so there is a circumstance
under which it's really important to get
these you know nutrients in right away
and that is if you are about to perform
again so if you are say at a track meet
where you're you're having one bed of
exercise and then you're gonna do
another one soon now again if you're
doing something really short you're
probably not depleting a ton of energy
and so you don't you don't need to get
calories and calories and calories a
small snack will do it but unless you're
going to perform again you know within
the next 10 or 12 hours something like
that it's perfectly fine to just have
your next meal have a regular meal eat
what you would eat you're going to be ok
again it's important to replenish those
carbs and the protein but getting you
know this really specific amount or
getting it in a particular window just
isn't nearly as important as you may
have been told so the anabolic window as
it's called and the indirect or the
intra workout glucose drinks and stuff
like that is what's the efficacy of
those yeah so it turns out you know here
the timing it's not the timing that's
magical it's the nutrients themselves so
like there are some studies looking at
timing of protein and it's like it
turned out that it didn't matter you
could eat the protein before the workout
or during the workout or after and like
the results were sort of the same it it
wasn't yeah that that perfect timing
that was making the difference it was
just that you were getting those
nutrients to begin with and so it looks
as though protein spread out throughout
the day is a really good approach rather
than trying to take it all in one bolus
right after a workout like it's it's
fine you want to have protein in your
diet you need to have carbs particularly
if you are doing endurance exercise and
I know I'm very familiar you know that
there's a debate going on about whether
yes high fat low carb diet is good good
for athletes and some people are
proposing that but I think a lot of
research is just showing that you know
when you exercise hard you do deplete
carbohydrates and that's what your
body's fueling itself on during those
those bouts I was gonna say what's your
stance on people doing marathons on keto
um I actually think I don't have like a
really strong stance on this so up if
you go and look I actually wrote a story
for 5:38 where I'm the lead science
writer a few years ago I believe the
headline was something like you can't
trust what you read about nutrition
maybe you can put it in the show notes
but basically looking at nutrition
studies and it turns out that nutrition
is just a really difficult thing to
study and a lot of the things that we
think that we know about nutrition are
based on pretty shoddy methodology and
studies that that aren't nearly as
definitive as we've been led to believe
I think that there are a lot of ideas
out there about diets a lot of it is
more sort of religion and science you
know people sort of take their stand and
I think that it's totally legitimate for
athletes to try different diets and you
know if someone finds that a keto diet
works for them go for it I don't see any
reason to tell them they absolutely
can't do that I'm not convinced that
it's performance-enhancing I mean there
was the Louise Burke did a study of race
Walker as elite race walkers where she
had them on this diet and it did not
seem to improve performance but you know
there are people that swear by it and I
do think that you died is something
that's worth playing around with on an
individual level but I think that we
just don't have the evidence on a level
of granularity that we want we want to
be able to say if you eat exactly this
much of this nutrient or this food or
this that or the other thing we'll get
this outcome but those things that we're
looking at are so complicated that it's
really hard to attribute that to one
food or to one component of food and so
what ends up happening is yeah you have
what are probably small effects getting
drowned added a lot of the noise with
the complexity of these issues that
you're looking at I got that I got that
completely I think sweating the small
stuff is you know
athletes seem to be super concerned that
their predigested vegan way that paleo
and and ethically sourced from the
mountains of Kenya has been taken in
with the right blend of MCT oil this
this and you think yeah may is still in
a calorie deficit and you're training
four hours a day like you don't sweat
the small stuff focus on focus on the
big winners which I'm gonna guess is
making sure that you're eating enough
and eating a varied diet exactly exactly
and I think the other thing to note here
is that you know they're elite athletes
in sports that eat very different diets
you know and they're performing well so
you know one athlete you know if you're
a Norwegian skier you probably start the
day with toast and that brown sort of
sweet cheese that they like to eat you
know and that's not something that
people generally eat in the US but it
works fine and said but to say that you
know those Norwegians years are so fast
because of the the brown cheese is just
ridiculous right brown cheese is like
the most Norwegian food toast and brown
cheese is exactly what I thought
Norwegian people ate I'm okay so why
does Usain Bolt work well on chicken
nuggets oh well I think it's an example
of just showing that here you've got
this guy who's the world's best sprinter
right and like so you can you can decide
that he needs to eat this like super
specific special diet but what he
decided when he was at the Olympic
Village in Beijing and was worried about
eating the local food because it was
unfamiliar to him was that he was gonna
go for the thing that he knew he liked
he knew that you know he could digest it
without problems and so yeah he ate a
bunch of chicken nuggets at the Olympics
and won a bunch of gold medals and you
know to suggest that that the chicken
nuggets where the secret behind the gold
medal is is ridiculous
but I think you have to flip that around
and also say that you know had he eaten
something that we more traditionally
thought was you know the
performance-enhancing you know some of
the things you were mentioning you know
the the vegan protein or the you know
whatever it is it would be just as
ridiculous and so you know what's
important is that he got he replenished
the calories that he needed he got
protein he got carbohydrates he got you
know the basic nutrients
and so he was fine and I think that
one-one danger here is that if if the
things that you're doing for recovery or
if your nutritional needs so you're an
athlete you're on the road
competing and if it becomes so important
to you that you have this special
specific food that's hard to get that
just becomes a new source of stress and
it's it's kind of the opposite of
recovery and you're not doing yourself
any favors and chances are whatever
benefit you're getting from that special
food is being outweighed by the stress
that you're experiencing by you know
this need to procure it yeah I suppose
unless it's perhaps something that you
know that you can always carry with you
or whatever it might be right all right
you totally totally correct that so you
touched earlier on upon massage soft
tissue work foam rolling and other
techniques like that moving into that
what what does the science say yeah it's
really interesting so I think massage is
one of the most popular recovery
modalities I know I'm a huge fan I love
it I think most athletes like it and you
know would you look at the science
behind it there are a lot of claims that
are made so for instance that it's
flushing your blood that's getting
lactate lactic acid out of the muscles
and that that's important and I'll just
say that whenever someone tells me that
that something works by flushing lactic
acid I'm sort of like okay that that
doesn't hold up because you know we used
to think that lactic acid was what made
you sore after a hard workout and we now
know that that's not the case and
regardless it turns out that your
muscles are really good at clearing
lactic acid on their own so by the time
you're using one of these things that
lactic acid is probably gone to begin
with but with massage you know their
claims that are made about about this or
you know hormones or flushing lactic
acid and those don't seem to stand up
but what massage really does in almost
universally does is it makes people feel
good it makes someone lie down for an
hour and relax and yeah they're not
looking at their phone they're not
thinking about other things they're just
sort of actively relaxing and I think
you know at its most basic level that is
recovery you know anything that makes
you feel good anything that that allows
you to take some time out of your day
to really give your body a chance to
rejuvenate and to relax
that's recovery and that's working like
we could consider that working yeah so
one of my first ever episode is actually
with dr. Quinn henyk the doctor of
physical therapy for juggernaut training
systems and in that modest he he said
the sentence there is no scientific
basis to say that massage static
stretching or dynamic stretching does
anything on the mechanism that people
thinks it think that it does work on and
he used an analogy have you heard about
the experiment that was done using metal
tools to do soft tissue work on rats
have you seen this little minx now
little mice ACLS so they ruptured the
mice is a Ciel's and then they they did
some some work with steel tools and one
iteration of the study they used it soft
tissue work and and another one they
didn't do anything and they they did
find that in this iteration of the study
where they used this tool that the
recovery was quicker but what they
didn't explain was that the size of the
tool that they were using was a human
sized tool and the amount of pressure
that they were applying was human
pressure to a mouse and the the study he
run the the figures forward and
basically worked out that your flesh
would literally shear apart I would rip
apart before you created a 1% shear in
the motion tissue so you know I think
you're right and it's it's interesting
and also reassuring to hear that there
isn't there isn't massive amounts of
conflict between what what you've
discovered him what he says as well but
that I think people presumed that
they're they're lying on a foam roller
the vibrates because it's working out
adhesions in the muscle it's helping
with microscopic tears and stuff like
that and yet what the main mechanism
it's working on appears to be activating
the parasympathetic nervous system and
just getting people to calm down and be
in a state which is conducive to
recovery is that is that fair to say is
that you yeah you just explained it
right there I mean it's just as you said
that it's it's
so one thing this was sort of a
recurring theme in my book is that there
are a lot of things that people said
worked and claimed worked and really you
know we're like you can take this you
know over my dead body take this away
from me over my dead body but oftentimes
the explanations that were given didn't
hold up so it wasn't that it's not
working but it may just not be via the
mechanisms that they say and you've just
explained it quite well I'm about
massage and particularly things that
that seem to target fashio and it's
interesting because fascia is something
that's this is an area of a lot of
research right now and I think it's very
early days so there's a lot more we
don't know then that we do about Asha
and it may end up that you know there
are things that we have not yet you know
come to understand so you know in terms
of whether foam rolling is good or bad I
would say that right now the science
that we have suggests that you know a
lot of the way that it's working is
really through the nerve system it's
it's not so much that it's some physical
mechanism there but we're still you know
it's still early days with this so
there's lots to be discovered and semi
my advice here is just sort of like if
you're doing it and you feel like it
makes you feel better and you feel like
it's quote-unquote working then keep
doing it there's no like there's nothing
that I found that was oh my god foam
rolling is terrible stop doing it at the
same time I did not find any compelling
reason why it should be done so if
you're someone and I've had multiple
people tell me please tell me they can
stop foam rolling if you're one of those
people I give you I hereby give you
license to not do it need to take
custody of the lacrosse balls you can
mate with the foam roller in your kit
back and one thing that's just come to
my mind there did you look at recovery
and short bouts so let's say that
someone's doing a 5 by 1 mile or 5 by
400 meters with you know a couple of
minutes rest in between did you look at
that at that super short period recovery
and what people can do because I am used
to lying on the floor and hoping that
the world will stop spinning but I have
been told by numerous coaches that I
need to
stand the [ __ ] up yes did you look at
that a little bit so there there is some
there is some evidence potentially that
in that sort of scenario that a little
bit of massage can be helpful that
sometimes something cold might help but
really one thing that's really great is
just really light exercise I mean when I
was I school runner we used to call it a
warm down or warm up right and so but
that easy activity it could be you know
and the Tour de France often times
you'll see the guys spinning on their
trainers after a race but where you're
just sort of keeping the blood flow
going so that that you know that what
the muscles are warm that that you're
you're still doing some motion without
it being taxing and so why is that good
idea because you know for me as a lame
layperson thinking about the body I
think right it's worked as hard as it
can now it needs to not work as hard as
it can whereas this is more like a
middle ground right it's kind of a
middle ground and I'll just say that we
don't have compelling evidence that this
is like absolutely necessary and you
know an interesting thing that I learned
while working on this book is that so
many of the things that we do in sport
are based more on sort of like we've
been doing this it seems to work and
beliefs about like well this is how we
did it before and we've had success then
on hard scientific evidence and this
isn't to say that like people are don't
care about evidence or they're trying to
push off things that don't work but just
that the stuff is really hard to measure
sometimes and it's hard to study and so
if something's working there's a lot of
compelling or you know that's perceived
to be working there's you know
compelling reasons there in many cases
to keep doing it and so you know if we
don't know for sure whether it's good
then a lot of people will say well I
like it so yeah some cases that maybe
that's good enough yeah yeah so we
talked about the the cryo chamber stuff
like this these supercooled kind of
tanks that you step into right and it
goes to some insanely low temperature
yeah yeah it's quite an adrenaline
shall see just how cold does it fit I've
never been in one and you know I step
outside my door sometimes in the middle
of January in the north of England and I
think I could last for about five
seconds so it's about that cold evidence
to suggest it works I could not find any
compelling evidence that that these cryo
tanks were performance enhancing or
recovery enhancing that said and some of
the claims that are made about them are
just ridiculous I mean I have a scene in
the book where I'm sort of relying some
of the claims that have been made to me
by a purveyor of cryotherapy and the
sports science expert that I'm talking
about starts laughing because I mean
they're they're really that what other
claims things about
oxygenating the blood which of course
isn't a thing and you know doing all
these crazy hormone things but I think
at the end of the day why people like
this so much is I also have a whole
chapter in the book about placebos and
the placebo effect and I think it's
worth reading because one of the things
that get into there and it's probably
beyond the scope of our discussion here
but it's just how some people and some
coaches are using the placebo effect to
good for good so we kind of tend to
think of the placebo effect as
assignment well it doesn't work but it
turns out that you know our bodies are
really powerful and the expect an
expectation that we have can be you know
in some cases almost like a powerful
drug and so I don't think that this is
something we should dismiss and it is
worth thinking about whether it's
something to harness and I think that
you know my experience the craft chamber
really had a strong you know seem to be
set up to have a strong placebo effect
because there's pretty good evidence
that placebos that are unpleasant work
better than things that are pleasant or
that you don't have anything so like
taking a pill placebo pill is less
effective than having a placebo shot for
instance but the other thing I could say
so it turns out that cryotherapy the the
tanks are really popular among martial
arts fighters and I could totally
understand this because you get in there
and then you you get out and you just
have this like feeling of being totally
pumped and totally amped and it's just
this huge adrenaline rush and I can
totally get why that would feel great
before it match and just really get you
ready but in terms of like is this going
to make you recover better there's just
not good evidence for that
so the mechanism again what we're
talking about here is that it's how it
makes you feel and potentially the it's
making you think about your recovery and
spend some time on it what yeah what one
of the the super cool things that spoke
to dr. Greg Potter from University of
Leeds about the sleep expert was he said
that the the placebo effect is the most
reliable effecting on all the
pharmacology and if we were somehow able
to bottle a placebo we would have a
panacea any like oh yeah it's so
hilarious that's something that you've
got this thing which kind of doesn't
work but the fact that it doesn't work
is the reason it does work and it's this
like universal snake oil but it's
actually kind of good it's really it's I
find the concept my increasingly deep
understanding of what placebos can do
it's yeah I really really enjoy it so
moving forward what were some of the
crazier approaches for recovery that you
came across obviously crazier than super
cooling your body - like - hold all
right I think when someone asked me the
other day if there was anything but like
I refused to try and one of them they're
places now that you can go to get IV
injections of vitamins and things and
this is supposed to aid recovery and I
actually have a whole chapter in the
book about about supplements nutritional
supplements including vitamins and so I
said absolutely Dada and I could inject
these things I mean my research showed
that that none of these things were
likely to be helpful in the first place
and the idea of injecting them into my
bloodstream just seemed like foolishness
so the IV drips because there's America
it's not the same in the UK at the
moment but in America nice but I know
especially in that party towns like
Vegas you can go and get like a hangover
drip right you'd like you wake up
morning and you you suffer in a little
bit and then you go in and they they
fill you up with this with this drip and
you lie there for an hour and then you
hangover
he goes away oh yeah so the one that I
was at they actually had I was watching
there was a couple their dress didn't in
I'll just say clothes that made me think
that these were high-end parties they
had just flown in that morning from
party in Aspen so this is in Denver so
they just flown in specifically to get
this IV and you know it was clearly
intended to undo whatever damage they
may have done party my night before her
it's I find the whole concept of like a
medical procedure to undo a hangover I
mean to be fair I've had some hangovers
where I've wished the doctor would be
able to come and fix it so maybe it's
just morning Marie wished for such a
thing yeah no I totally get that so you
you mentioned that the the IV drips were
in there with the craziest stuff was
that was there anything else that you
came across that you were surprised by
or couldn't believe yeah okay so I live
in Colorado
I'll just preface this I saying and so
we're at high altitude and so and we get
a lot of tourists and so people worry
about the altitudes and whatnot but I
was seeing in multiple places that I
went these oxygen and hailers so the
ideas you inhale this straight oxygen
and that was going to make you feel
better which you know if you had a
medical condition or were truly you know
low in oxygen that could be helpful I
think anyone who's really an athlete and
in decent shape is probably not in that
category and it's just not going to be
helping you would be even at higher
altitude of the order that those places
in Colorado are it's that's not going to
be the thing that's that's you know the
limiting factor in your recovery you've
touched upon it their altitudes chambers
I'm gonna guess or a commonly used to
live Tour de France athletes and
endurance athletes I suppose yeah they
are and these aren't you so to say these
aren't used so much for recovery as for
training so it's really about getting
adaptations and whatnot but they do seem
it's interesting the literature shows
that there may be responders and lesser
responders to altitude which is kind of
interesting some people go to altitude
or use an altitude chamber and really
get more red blood cells and whatnot and
others don't I think we're still trying
to sort of figure out how that all lays
out but these have been used for a long
time and seem to be an effective
training tool particularly if you're
going to be competing at altitude that
is super interesting it's I guess again
as you said earlier on horses for
courses right there you need to kind of
learn learn what works for you so one
thing that way to touch on before we
finish up was did you find any
particular individuals who have an
unnatural ability to recover or some
people who have particularly poor
abilities to recover is there a big
swing with regards to that absolutely
and I think that this is I mean this is
in a way similar I think it's a
different skill or a different talent
but just as some people respond really
quickly or really well to training there
are some people that need more or less
recovery and I talked about one person
in the book her name is Camille heron
she's an ultra-marathoner and she seems
to have just a supernatural ability to
recover it's quite remarkable she kind
of got into the ultra endurance events
after figuring out that she could do
marathons in a row and you know there
are people that do many marathons you
know seven marathons in seven days and
things like that but usually they're
sort of in it to to finish and which is
a huge accomplishment
yeah she's someone who can actually
perform at a high level doing that and
she is now doing ultra marathons she
currently holds the world record for one
under me I'm sorry a 100-mile run for
any person of any gender on a certified
course so she's she's an amazing athlete
and she seems to really hundred mile run
he's currently held by a female mm-hmm
that's right
that he's crazy why do you think that is
I think it's because she's an
extraordinary athlete and if you're
asking why you know is this the event
there's yeah this is a whole topic of
conversation that's been ongoing for a
long time you know is there an event
where women could have performed men and
there's a lot of thought that maybe you
know if there was such a thing an
endurance event might be that because
of differences in metabolism and things
like that so that may be part of it I
also think that this is an event you
know that she is someone who was very
elite and it's probably some of it is
that these things are somewhat new
they're not entirely new
but yeah I think she's just an
incredible athlete and I don't think
that her her biggest accomplishments are
yet behind her Wow I mean that's to have
to have a an event like that which is it
ultra ultra running where you wouldn't
have considered a woman to be winning
the hundred meters and you roll that
forward and you go well why is 100 miles
any different as far as you know I
didn't know that fact and in my
experience the main endurance event that
women had an advantage in as far as I
knew was swimming long distance swimming
because of the particular makeup of
their body and changes in buoyancy and
their ability to move through the water
and stuff like that but to hear that the
100 mile race is one is currently held
by a woman that's that's really cool
yeah yeah it really is it's awesome
so Christy can you tell the listeners
where they can find you online and why
they can find your book yeah so my book
is www good to go book calm and you can
find me on twitter at craig crest that
CRA g CR EST as in like craig craggy
crest
it's a place Dave it's it's actually the
name of my favorite trail run and then
my website is my name Christian done
calm fantastic I will make sure that the
link to good to go and all of your
socials push all some good articles that
we've spoken about will be in the
showcase below I had one other little
thing to plug and that is next month so
in mid-february
of 2019 I am launching a new podcast
it's a little bit of a departure from
what we've been talking about but it's
called emerging form and it's a podcast
about the creative process my co-host is
a poet and we basically spend 30 minutes
each episode talking about some creative
conundrums and then we bring on a guest
to help us answer some questions and I
do think that there are a couple of
episodes that would be interesting
though to athletes as well one of the
ones that
really like is about talent and whether
it's necessary and so we have a pretty
good debate about that Sanna you guys
fascinating yeah you can find it it
hasn't launched yet but it will soon
and it's at emerging form calm amazing
well once that's up make sure that you
send it across and I will fire out to
the listeners but in the meantime
hopefully we will have helped some
people understand their recovery I
genuinely think that if if everyone was
to go back and listen to Alex such
instance episode where he talks about
endurance and then comes to this
hopefully we've got you know your
training saw it and you know yeah you're
our PE and then you've got your recovery
side and you've got your our PR and now
you just need to go and sleep and then
lift some weights that's right thank you
very much for your time thank you for
coming on today
oh thank you for having me it's been my
pleasure
[Music]